♪
>> WELCOME BACK TO "THE BIG SUN
SHOW."
TOMORROW THE JURY WILL GET THE
CASE OF THE CHRISTOPHER STEELE
DOSSIER SOURCE WHO WAS CHARGED
AS PART OF THE ONGOING DURHAM
PROBE INTO THE RUSSIAN COLLUSION
HOAX.
TESTIMONY REVEALED THE FBI
OFFERED TO PAY CHRISTOPHER
STEELE $1 MILLION FOR
INFORMATION AND EVEN AFTER THE
BUREAU COULDN'T VERIFY THE
CLAIMS, THE FBI STILL USED THE
INFORMATION TO FILE FOR A FISA
WARRANT.
AN FBI ANALYST ALSO TESTIFIED
IGOR DANCHENKO WAS ON THE FBI'S
PAYROLL FOR YEARS.
NOW THE RANKING MEMBER OF THE
HOUSE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE SAYS
HE PLANS TO HOLD FBI LEADERSHIP
ACCOUNTABLE.
>> WE HAVE A HUGE PROBLEM WITH
THE FBI, AND THE FACT IS THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE LOST
CONFIDENCE IN THE FBI.
IT'S BEEN POLITICIZED FOR AT
LEAST SIX YEARS NOW, AND IT'S
GOING IN THE WRONG DIRECTION.
WE DON'T NEED THE LEADERSHIP WE
HAVE NOW.
THEY SHOULD RESIGN, THEY SHOULD
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR
WRONGDOING.
>> NOW, I LOVE THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE REPUBLICANS ON THE RECORD
NOW BEFORE THE ELECTION THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THIS AND HOLD THESE PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE BECAUSE WE'VE GOT --
THERE'S REAL ROT IN THE FBI.
BUT, NICOLE, AND OBVIOUSLY THE
DANCHENKO TRIAL, THERE'S NO
PREDICTING WHAT A JURY'S GOING
TO DO.
BUT WHAT IS THE BIG PICTURE SORT
OF TAKEAWAY RIGHT NOW?
>> YOU KNOW, IT'S INTERESTING.
SO DANCHENKO'S ON TRIAL, FIVE
COUNTS, FOR LYING TO THE FBI,
ESSENTIALLY, AND ONE OF THE
COUNTS WERE ACTUALLY JUST
DROPPED IN THE LAST COUPLE OF
DAYS.
BUT IF ANYBODY IS LISTENING TO
WHY IT GOT DROPPED, IT JUST
TELLS ME WHAT A CIRCUS THIS
ENTIRE PROCESS IS RIGHT NOW.
SO HE ESSENTIALLY, HE WAS
CHARGED FOR LYING TO THE FBI
BECAUSE HE SAID HE NEVER TALKED
TO A DEMOCRATIC -- TO THE
DEMOCRATIC OPERATIVE, CHARLES
DOLAN, WHO WORKS FOR THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN.
WELL, YOU'RE RIGHT, HE DIDN'T
TALK TO CHARLES DOLAN, BUT THEY
SURE DID E-MAIL EACH OTHER.
BUT BECAUSE HE WAS BEING CHARGED
WITH TALKING, HE SAID HE DIDN'T
TALK TO THEM, THEY SAID, WELL,
TECHNICALLY HE DIDN'T TALK TO
THEM, HE MAILED THEM, SO WE'RE
DROPPING THIS CHARGE.
I MEAN, THIS IS JUST BEYOND
ASININE FOR ME, AND I CAN'T WRAP
MY HEAD AROUND THIS.
WHAT I DON'T UNDERSTAND IS THIS
WEEK YOU HAD DO DOLAN ACTUALLY
TESTIFY, AND HE SAID I GOT MY
INFORMATION FROM A GOP
OPERATIVE, BUT THE TRUTH WAS
THEY WERE JUST RUMORS, I
ACTUALLY HEARD IT ON CABLE NEWS.
[LAUGHTER]
WELL, THESE RUMORS MADE IT INTO
THE DOSSIER WHICH MADE IT INTO
THE FISA WARRANT APPLICATION.
I MEAN, THE WHOLE SYSTEM'S JUST
BROKEN.
>> EXACTLY.
AND, AGAIN, THE PROBLEM IS
YOU'VE ALWAYS HAD LIARS IN THE
WORLD.
THE PROBLEM IS THE COPS, THE
GOOD GUYS, NEED TO BE ABLE TO
DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN THEM AND
GET THE GOOD INFORMATION.
AVENUE LIBERTY SHAH, YOU KNOW --
ALICIA, OBVIOUSLY, THIS IS
PRETTY DAMNING, I THINK, FOR THE
FBI.
DO YOU HAVE ANY FAITH THAT WE
MIGHT GET PROGRESS?
>> WELL, I DON'T, I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT FAITH --
[LAUGHTER]
>> VERY WISE.
>> I DO KNOW EVERY SINGLE TODAY
THERE'S A NEW DETAIL THAT I
THINK CAUSES AMERICANS TO
REALLY, YOU KNOW, CASTS A SHADOW
OF DOUBT CAN ON THE ROLE OF THE
FBI THAT IT PLAYS IN THE UNITED
STATES NOW.
IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE A LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY, BUT IT'S
DOING SOMETHING MUCH DIFFERENT
NOW.
IT'S BECOME SO POLITICAL THAT
PEOPLE, I THINK, OUT THERE, THEY
DON'T TRUST IT ANYMORE.
WE KNOW LAWMAKERS, AND YOU BRING
UP A REALLY GOOD POINT ABOUT
MIDTERMS.
IF REPUBLICANS TAKE CONGRESS, IF
THEY'RE GOING TO FOLLOW THROUGH
ON SOME OF THESE PROMISES THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO HOLD THE FBI
ACCOUNTABLE.
>> TYRUS, WHISTLEBLOWER STEVE
FRIEND TOLD DAN BONGINO LAST
NIGHT -- LISTEN TO THIS CLIP.
>> THE OATH THAT WE TOOK WHEN WE
BECAME SPECIAL AGENTS DOES HAVE
MEANING, AND I'VE BECOME FOND OF
SAYING THAT THE OATH DOESN'T
RETIRE, IT DOESN'T GET
SUSPENDED.
THE FBI'S FIDELITY, BRAVERY AND
INTEGRITY MOTTO HAS TO MEAN
SOMETHING TO THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE WORKING ON A DAY-TO-DAY
BASIS, AND I HOPE MORE WILL COME
FORWARD.
IT'S TIME TO STEP UP, IT'S TIME
TO REALLY BE THE PEOPLE THAT WE
WERE CALLED TO WHEN WE
ORIGINALLY APPLIED TO BECOME
SPECIAL AGENTS OF THE FINISHING
OR BI.
>> ANOTHER THING THAT HE SAID IN
THAT INTERVIEW WAS THAT THE FBI
WAS USING THE ARRESTS FROM THE
JANUARY 6TH STUFF AND SORT OF
PADDING THEIR DOMESTIC TERRORISM
NUMBERS AROUND THE COUNTRY TO
MAKE IT SEEM LIKE DOMESTIC
TERRORISM IS WORSE THAN IT
REALLY IS.
I MEAN, WHAT, WHAT DO YOU DO
ABOUT THIS?
>> WELL, LIKE I SAID, AGAIN,
IT'S NOT FBI, IT'S THE PEOPLE
WHO DECIDED A COUP AGAINST THE
UNITED STATES WHO HAPPEN TO
WEAR, WORE THE BADGE.
BUT WHAT HE WERE DOING, WHY THEY
WERE DOING IT, THEY WERE TRYING
TO RAISE THE NUMBERS.
YOU DIDN'T NEED TO RAISE
NUMBERS.
YOU COULD HAVE JUST LOOKED AT
THE RIOTING WE SAW, THE THE
LOOTING WE SAW, THE CRIME STUFF
WE'RE STILL HAVING IN THE NAME
OF ANTIFA OR WHATEVER LEFT-WING
OUTFIT THEY'RE DOING WHEN THEY
COMMIT CRIME.
THOSE NUMBERS WERE PRETTY, COULD
PAD THEMSELVES.
BUT THEY NEEDED THEM TO BE MAGA,
THEY NEEDED THEM TO BE --
>> RIGHT.
>> THEY FORGOT THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO GO TO WORK EVERY TODAY AND
COMPLAIN IN THE RIGHT WAY.
THEY NEEDED JANUARY 6TH TO BE
BIGGER BECAUSE, AGAIN, WHO HAS
BEEN A TARGET IN THIS WHOLE
THING?
IT'S BEEN PRESIDENT TRUMP CANNOT
RUN AGAIN.
THAT'S THE OATH THAT THEY TOOK
OVER THE FBI.
SO, OF COURSE, WE NEED TO LOOK
LIKE THERE'S A MAGA ATTACK IN
EVERY CITY AND ALL OVER COUNTRY
AND IT'S RUNNING RAMPANT AND
HEIR BURNING DOWN CITIES AND
FLAGS ETC., BUT THEY'RE NOT
DOING THAT.
WHENEVER YOU DO SOMETHING
ILLEGAL, WHENEVER YOU'RE GOING
TO DO A COUP AND TAKE SOMEBODY
OUT, YOU HAVE TO CREATE IT.
AND LUCKILY, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
HAVE SEEN THROUGH THIS, AND NOW,
HOPEFULLY, THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS WHO
DECIDED TO PUT THEIR BELIEFS OR
THEIR ISSUES OVER THE VOTERS OF
THE UNITED STATES, OVER THE
GOVERNMENT AND OVER VOW THEY
TOOK WILL BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
THERE NEEDS TO BE HEARING, THESE
PEOPLE NEED TO BE BROUGHT TO
JUSTICE, A